but first we've known Jackie Evancho as  a classical singer ever since her debut  on America's Got Talent at age 10 in  2010 to now Jackie is changing things up  and going pop with her new single  apocalypse gotta go cool I kind of  wanted to experiment in that world  because I've been singing classical  music since I was really young but I'm  not going to permanently stay in the pop  world it's just kind of to experiment  I'm young and you know want to break the  barrier and Jackie who just turned 16  tells us she has other career goals too  singing is my main passion and right now  that's what I'm concentrating on so once  I master that then I can you know bring  in the modeling and acting